so you might recall we first look at
inverse functions generally speaking and
then we said okay cool now we don't they
are let's look at some of the fancy
stuff like the inverse of an increasing
function education pregnant the
investment odd function we understood
them a little better we so dug into it
and we did the same thing here what do
you already know about the inverse trig
functions and their graphs it was the
first lesson what did we come up okay if
we have a look at ya yes all right sure
so when you think about the concatenate
and the shape of these investor graphs
they do share some domain and range and
we looked at how to modify the domain of
range where we did what to them what was
the second message after that kiss
mornings what did we do to perhaps
Asians yeah we transformed them we are
we reflect we can translate and we can
scale like Spanish and this one it's an
opportunity so now we're gonna dig a
little bit further and think about what
are the properties what kind of
interesting things can we notice like
interesting patents like the inverse of
an increasing this increases that kind
of level bit so first we have a look at
this now some of you will have seen this
result before but if you have it I'm
going to address it from like never
looked at this at all if we never think
about sign of it just look at this for a
second okay now the whole idea is that
even though it's not exclusively about
anchors you can think of this as an
angular to try to sine inverse of X it's
an angle right if you take sine of an
angle it gives you a ratio this is
taking the ratio or handing
being okay so this is an angle and then
this is another angle
what happens when we add these two
together we make two arguments the first
one's like a simple geometric one is a
bit of a cheat the second one is a bit
more rigorous and it's based on the
ground okay so remembering that these
are about angles draw for me a tree now
sine inverse of X it exists inside a
triangle of some kind it's an angle in a
triangle so for instance if I were to
say let's give this thing your name
let's call this thing let's call this
angle theta okay I've got a right angle
in this triangle so if I call this guy
over here theta
what can I say I could save a write it
but what's one thing I could say about
the lengths of the sides in my triangle
okay good so this is remember it takes a
ratio and it hands back an angle so this
is kind of a ratio in disguise I could
say in a variety of ways but x over one
will do and sine is about which pair
sides officer but everybody's very good
so if I say this is opposite and this is
half on this how did that look does that
make sense
sine inverse of X on one plate someone
that will hand me back to theta so good
okay now have you look at this
where's closed inverse of X where's that
is this guy over here oh it's adjacent
on hypotenuse this one way I could say
it is it another way I can do this
though it's another way I can do this
how look at this other angle over here
what is this angle in this particular
triangle I'm in I'm in I could say 90
ways I mean vestry gland I've put
calculus up sort of put it as part of my
like brain so I'm not really gonna try
and do degrees I'm gonna try to avoid
them as much nicely just really clouds
so you - think I'm right this is the
compliment
do you agree okay now I could say I
could say because inverse of X is going
to be like I can phrase in terms of this
guy what is this guy by the way I can
find it quite easily I swear it off
that's that's just straight path Tigers
butts a bit messy to go for that guy
right I would prefer to have a look at
the guy in the corner he's going to here
and say how are these two angles related
cause inverse of X is not just a Jason I
have one user here it's the opposite and
hypotenuse of a different angle
which one yeah it's the opposite of
hypotenuse sorry the adjacent by
hypotenuse it obvious angle do you see
that x over one there's the x over one
to say one then right so therefore if
this is Theta then this angle
is this blue guy over here do you agree
with that like that's the angle it's
referring to running out of fingers to
14 swiping on it so this guy is PI on to
take away theta right so therefore if I
add an angle to its complement which
after all that's what cosine means
complement of side okay therefore this
thing should just be peyote
do you agree with that do you see the
way I reasoned it this is talking about
angle maybe this well he's talking about
another angle this guy over here
adjacent hypotenuse all right now this
is a K except the argument when it works
naturally in an acute abide angle
triangle and therefore it puts a
restriction on feet namely that it must
be accused okay I can do a little better
than just because sine inverse in closet
mus don't just exist from naught to PI
on to they just did one okay so instead
of appealing to a triangle I'm going to
appeal to graph kind of - so would you
draw a certain axis for me but make it
be enough that we can fit such a side of
us by signing this and cos inverse
together you do that for me one graph
okay now what I have left off of this is
I have no one under actual values here
right so I've got my cos inverse graph
in green I've got my citing this graph
in blue where's my domain restriction
negative one to one so I'm gonna slap
that guy in there and including both
graphs
what's my range restriction how far down
the guy
negative time to all the way up to pine
and I've got zero and plan to as stop us
in the middle okay so everything should
be nice and evenly spaced out now what
I'm doing here is I'm saying okay well
this guy up here the extension systems
are very few minutes but even in
extension what we can say look I'm
adding these together right add even
together some points easy at some point
too high let's do the easy ones first
okay for instance let me here where my
left right when x equals negative 1 I
know what the sine inverse graph is
equal to and I also know what the cause
in this graph is equal to negative power
2 plus pi take your final two plus pi
it's a play on two right so I should be
up then okay so that is in line with
both of these okay all the way over
there it was in the same way if I move
over to X equal zero that's the next
easy point at x equals zero this
ordinate Y value is 0 plus PI or to do
then there is and one last one over here
they swap sides so here cuz it most is
now zero and sine inverse has come up to
play or two so you can see I must go
through these three black points in
addition to that when you think about
blue plus green yeah see how this guy's
increasing at exactly the same rate as
this guy is decreasing do you see that
right so this this symmetry here and it
goes all the way across because this
guy's always increasing and this guy's
always decreasing and they are doing
that at exactly the same rate
okay so therefore really what I've got
here is this line and this line of
course is y equals PI on two because we
have that interpret when the middle just
very easy
now this is a nicer argument because it
extends the domain right it says the
domain and you can see it but this is
true for more values than just in my own
level might even find a little bit
however it's not yet complete to really
really make this rigorous and we will
finish this or I really need to argue is
you know how I said all of this is
increasing at the same rate as this is
decreasing I just kind of said that I
just kind of threw it out
but on the basis of Awesomeness on my
graph but you don't need that
partly because maybe around all sort of
wine what to do we have to use to prove
that one thing is increasing at exactly
the same rate
and yeah we need to be able to
differentiate these things okay now I've
already established how to differentiate
sine constant and it's a bit of an extra
step to do sine inverse cos inverse in
spannabis but we will do that tomorrow
and then this proof be rigorous okay
it's like yes without a shadow of a
doubt not only these three points which
are easy to see but all the ones in
between will be able to know okay we can
prove that they're all there make sense
okay
now this is a really important result
this is really important was also put a
big box around it